Speaker 1: . So Republicans in Congress. Congress
people in general are often shielded from
the rules that they put in
place for others, oftentimes
Congress people will skirt the law. Sometimes they
will act brazenly, as is the case with Matt Gates.
And I have covered him on my channel for a
while now, this case that's rolling through,
this investigation that's happening, the
Justice Department looking into his untoward,
immoral behavior with children, which
is an interesting thing since he's
touring the country with the Kuhnen Princess
Marjorie Taylor Green and Save the Children.
Is there their motto? Well, Matt Gates, his
associate, Joel Greenberg, is now actually
cooperating with the government and it's not
looking good for little Maddy Gates. ABC says
Gates associate providing feds Intel documents
as probe into congressman continues sources.
Former tax collector Joel Greenberg is cooperating
with investigators. None of this is good news for
Matt Gates. They were thick as thieves. These
two sending Venmo payments to underage girls
with notes like books for school. To add insult to
injury, as the federal investigation into Florida
Rep. Matt Gates continues into the summer. Sources
tell ABC News that Gates is one time winchman
has been steadily providing information and
handing over potential evidence that could
implicate the Florida congressman and others and
others and others in the sprawling probe. Former
Seminole County tax collector Joel Greenberg, as
part of his ongoing cooperation with prosecutors,
has provided investigators with years of Venmo
and cash transactions and thousands of photos
and videos, as well as access to personal
social media accounts, sources said. Again,
not good, not good on its face that Matt Gates is
a creeper. A sickening, vile alleged pedophile.
But also that this this man is the leader of the
Republican Party. A stalwart. Example for young
Republicans everywhere, and this is what we got.
Private messages exclusively reviewed by ABC News
potentially shed new light on the process by
which Greenberg allegedly met women online
who were paid for sex and introduced them to
the Florida congressman and other associates.
This investigation isn't just going
to end here. There will likely be
other powerful people within the infrastructure
of Florida leadership who are implicated in this.
Greenberg pleaded guilty in May to multiple
federal crimes, including sex trafficking of a
minor and introducing her to other quote unquote,
adult men who also had sex with her when she was
under age. Greenberg agreed to provide, quote,
substantial assistance, unquote, to prosecutors
as part of their ongoing investigation
that Gates should be quaking in his boots.
Instead, he's touring the country on his Magga
parade. Trying to to whip up crowds into a frenzy
and maybe incite another insurrection,
the first of which he was so fond.